so our lives and everything we do is
nothing but a ballet of the conversion
of energy from one form into another do
you know what the french word is for
energy I do not calorie calorie okay
so when we consume food a one for one
definition of calorie is energy so what
happens if you consume more calories it
creates chemical potential energy in the
form of fat I'm not fat I'm just filled
with potential you see this this is
potential that's the inefficiency of
your body so that inefficiency gets
converted to heat so your body heats up
when you exercise in the same way you
drive a car the car heats up in the same
way the wheels and the tracks of a
roller coaster are actually getting hot
because of this inefficiencies and every
conversion of energy from one form to
another
thank you
[Music]